each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
we'll start with Clark Barrett whom you
probably know but who got his PhD at
stanford and number of years ago now and
it's now New York University and I
learned this morning was also a summer
intern here at microsoft research in
1993 so welcome okay alright so I think
maybe a couple of you may have seen this
talk at PT pardoning if you see it ok
good Madonn you saw all right you saw it
so I have a little more time today so
I'm going to go through parts of it a
little more carefully but but certainly
if you have questions let me know just
to kind of set the context for this like
rishton said Cesare and I are now the
the sort of joint project leads of the
latest version of the CVC project which
we've called for lack of imagination CBC
three actually trying to build on our
brand name I guess but it's it's it's
exciting and one of the one of the
reasons we're here at Microsoft is we're
really interested in in getting more
more interfaces with people who really
need their improving tools and we're
interested in what kind of features you
need we're interested in hooking up real
systems and getting all this stuff to
work of course you have lots of their
improving expect expertise here but our
hope is that we can learn from each
other and no continue to push things
forward in this what I think is becoming
a very exciting field the automated
reasoning and especially the
satisfiability modulo theories alright
so the talk today is about a particular
theory the theory of recursive data
types also known as algebraic data types
or term algebras there's various names
that people thrown around for this over
the years so less important the name I
guess is the definition so let's let's
talk about what it is the idea here is
you have simple data types built up
using type constructors and then type
selectors and type testers that you use
to recover the data that was built up
with constructors now the most obvious
example of course is the old list
example where we define a constructor
cons that can build a list out of some
at we're we're dealing with assorted
logic here so we have the type int the
type list and then null would be a nulla
reconstructor that takes no arguments
now you're certainly familiar with his
data type and you know in functional
languages you can build up arbitrary
data types like this the thing that
maybe is a little bit interesting is how
does how do you actually now model this
in force or logic it's actually it's not
too difficult so the idea is we
introduce a sort for each data type and
then each constructor and selector is a
function symbol for sort of logic and
the testers become predicate symbols and
then you can write formulas about these
kinds of data types with things like
this you could say for all X that is
natural successor of X is not equal to 0
let's see I think I had a definition of
that here oh yeah here's here's another
you can define nach the natural type as
having two constructors the 0
constructor and the successor
constructor with the corresponding
selector or destructor predecessor okay
so example of a formula you might write
is for all X of type net the successor
of X is not equal to 0 and similarly a
list is either null or it's constructed
using the cons constructor so probably
it's not too difficult to see the the
correspondence between the functional
data type as you might define in ml or
scheme or something and
and these logical formulas that say
something about those data types and
what we were interested in is then you
know suppose we want to reason about
these things what's the best way to do
it so in order to to look at this
problem more generally we want to
consider just a generic data type that
has an arbitrary number of constructors
and each constructor can be built with
zero or more arguments all of possibly
different sorts including the sort being
constructed and then you have testers
for each constructor now in the paper we
actually have a slight extension of this
so not only can you have multiple
constructors you can also have mutually
recursive data types and it turns out
that that extension is is very easy to
do it's just a simple matter whether
it's one of the rules you just changed a
little bit in the decision procedure and
it it works very nicely with recursive
types as well or mutually recursive I
should say Bell folk is just on a single
type for this talk okay and then you can
write it this way it's a little more
compact and maybe easier to read you
just list all the constructors and you
list each selector within the
constructor that it belongs to and then
the type for each selector is listed
there as well or the sort alright so
that's the the general framework
and each each of these s is there the
lowercase s is is either an external
sort like a an int or a bowl or
something or it's one of the sorts being
defined by your recursive data type as a
technical point we're assuming when when
we look at the semantics of this well
actually even the syntax we assume that
we have an infinite number of constant
symbols of the non RTT types we don't
actually need that for the decision
procedure but it simplifies the
exposition all right so now I told you
what the syntax is we have these
constructor symbols selector symbols
tester symbols and now the question is
how do we interpret these what is the
semantics and the semantics we're
interested in is actually the semantics
of a particular model so the model is
just the term model and what you do is
you just look at the constructors and
then your infinite number of constants
over the base types and then you can
build arbitrary terms look at all the
ground terms you can build with those
symbols that's your term model and
that's the model that we're interested
in in terms of is there can we satisfy a
particular formula in that model okay
it's a very natural model it's it's the
model that you would expect but that's
just to be precise okay and then once
you have the model you can talk about
the interpretation of the various
symbols in the model so the testers are
just true if the term that they're
applied to evaluates to as something
that was constructed with the
appropriate constructor a selector if
it's applied to the corresponding
constructors to notice I have s sub J
applied to constructor C sub J then it
just selects out the Cape argument now
one of the tricks with this
theory is you have this this partial
function problem which is it's perfectly
legal in first order logic to apply any
function symbol to any a term and so we
can apply a selector symbol to some
constructor that was built with a
different that would turn those built
with a different constructor so it turns
out that people define this in various
ways over the years and really when
you're thinking about applications the
definition of this doesn't matter so
much because typically what you want to
do is check that this never happens or
that if it does happen it can't affect
the the value of your formula so so
there are various ways to do that and so
we essentially just just say you can
choose some arbitrary ground term and
and defying the theory that way see ya
so so notice that one thing that people
have done in the past for this is just
to define this to be the identity
operation we can't quite do that because
we're we're really k we care about the
underlying sorts so a selector has a
particular type signature and so it has
to return something of the right type
and the thing its applied to maybe of
the wrong type so the easiest way to
deal with this was just to say you're
allowed to designate an arbitrary ground
term of the appropriate type and we'll
just use that okay now the question
we're interested in is let's see if we
can determine the satisfiability of an
arbitrary set of literals with the
syntactic form i showed you over the
model R which is this term model okay so
it's a well-defined problem now we know
what the syntax is we know what the
intended model is we have semantics for
all the operations so now it's just a
question of how do you decide it what's
the what's the best way to do it and
actually when I first looked at this
problem people had implementations of it
it's been around for a while and I
looked at the literature and the thing
that I found a little bit frustrating
was nobody had really covered the
problem in this level of generality and
at the level of an implementation that
you could that you could actually use
and so what I thought was just going to
be an exercise in understanding what had
been done turned into some original
research so what what is out there
there's this original work by often that
is probably the most cited in terms if
you look in the current literature's
people say well this problem was solved
by often the problem with that is first
of all it's a very difficult procedural
description of the algorithm but more
importantly he only considers the case
of a single constructor so if you really
are interested in this more general case
with multiple recursive types with
multiple constructors it doesn't the
generalization is not straightforward
and then there was this work at Stanford
I want amanha students who actually did
all kinds of crazy stuff with term
algebra is combined with length
constructors and quantifier elimination
some impressive work but he considered
the quantifier free part of it to be
trivial so much so that they they give a
very simple non deterministic algorithm
for it in about a paragraph and it is
true that this works but unfortunately
it's not at all an efficient algorithm
so if you're interested in doing this in
practice you have to ask yourself what
how would you implement this so and then
okay and then there's also some related
work using superposition for this but
they're even they're also quite far
removed from the implementation level so
we're interested in actually
implementing this in our theorem prover
and the questions we had is how do we do
this in an efficient way
okay so before I show you the procedure
one important concept if you are
familiar with some of this work you'll
you may recognize this but one important
concept in understanding how the rules
work is this idea of a term graph so
essentially what you can do is you want
to look at a term the syntactic form of
a turn and think of the associated graph
in terms of how things line up in the
underlying model right so notice here
that if I have a formula like this with
cons XY equals z and x equals carb w and
so on x and y our children of cons
because this the cons term is
constructed from x and y but over here w
is a parent of car and coder of w
because those are children of w in the
underlying representation so it's kind
of interesting because sometimes the
function symbol goes down the graph and
sometimes the function symbol goes up
the graph but if you understand the
underlying representation it's clear why
so this kind of a graph is useful in
understanding how to how the rules work
okay so i'm going to show you the rules
and i'm going to show you how the rules
work by several examples i think that's
by far the easiest way to understand it
and there's I i have to say there's
nothing particularly deep here I don't
think we just there's a couple of
interesting ideas but what was important
to me was by the time we were done it we
had a nice algorithm is easy to prove
correct terminating complete and is very
straightforward to map this into an
implementation and one of the really
nice features of this is we use I've
become a big believer in this abstract
presentation rule-based presentation of
decision procedures because it allows
you if you give a procedural
representation things are very sort of
interlocked but
if you give this rule-based presentation
I think we have maybe 20 different rules
each rule is very is pretty simple once
you understand it and it's completely
independent from the other rules and
it's only the proofs that you have to
look at the interactions between the
rules and make sure they terminate and
are sound and complete and so on
actually termination and completion is
where I have to look at the interaction
of the rules so the nice thing is when I
was implementing this I was able to just
take a run rule at a time figure out how
best to plug it into the system I could
test out you know a subset of the rules
make sure they were working and I think
this was really the greatest success of
this work was kind of as a proof of
concept of this way of presenting
decision procedures so I'm a big
believer in giving a nice abstract role
based decision procedure alright so the
first set of rules if you're familiar
with abstract congruence closure we we
stole several ideas from that and the
first set of rules are just flattening
rules which allow you to essentially
label each term in your term structure
with some abstract variable which
represents an equivalence class so the
way this works is here's here's this
little running example we have cons XY
equals z x equals carve w y equals
cutter wws not equals Z and W is is cons
so so the first thing we do is we use
this this arrow to to represent the
labeling of a node with a particular
abstraction variable so this is the
flattening rule so we flattened by
assigning everything its own abstraction
variable the v's or the abstraction
variables so x y and z get abstraction
variables then cons of v2 v3 that's
that's what used to be cons of XY gets
assigned an abstract variable and so on
so we've got seven different abstract
variables here corresponding to the
terms in our formula and then for each
abstract formula or for each abstract
variable we have a labeling and the
labeling represent
the possible constructors that term
could have been constructed with and
this is how we're going to take care of
the problem of multiple constructors
we're going basically at first all bets
are off anything could have been
constructed with anything and we're
slowly going to try to figure out which
constructors were used and maybe see if
we can avoid making decisions about some
of those things and that's going to save
us on efficiency yeah you do this in the
ground for use in addition to the ground
well well again this is an abstract
representation of the of the algorithm
so in the abstract representation these
are additional annotations so this
labeling is explicit sintac syntax in
our abstract description but of course
if you are implementing it you may you
may just annotate the egress itself or
the term structure just in much the same
way as we in the implementation we don't
actually add these abstraction variables
those are just the equivalence classes
okay good good question okay so to begin
with everything could this is in the
theory of lists here and everything
could have been constructed with either
cons or null except a v4 and the reason
is that in our abstraction rule if you
abstract a cons you means you
immediately label it with just the
constructor because there's there's no
need to consider other possibilities all
right and everything else is just is
just factoring out that abstraction and
so are our term graph here at the bottom
just looks like this so v4 and b5 are
the are the cons nodes and so on all
right and these are I don't even have
the rules there but but essentially they
just introduce those variables and don't
do anything else except if you have
strack t'akons which introduces that
labeling yeah so you're not going to
infer that Levi is upon
go down to a cop no because in fact
that's not even a plot like it like I
said before in the in the theory that I
presented its ok to apply a car to a non
cons note it's a maybe a degenerate case
but the theory we're deciding allows
that because we don't have any mechanism
and force or logic to not allow that
essentially so any mechanism you have
has to be built on top of it not not
within the theory itself it's good
question alright then we have some
simple rules this is not worth spending
much time on but essentially it says if
I know that too equivalence classes or
abstract variables are equal then I
orient them in a certain way this is
essentially in order to pick one
equivalence class to represent both of
them and we just have a total ordering
on we assume a tall order in on these
equivalence classes or abstract
variables if we know that we have a
violation of reflexivity we can drive
and consistent and then we can always
remove these tester variables just by
reflecting the same information using
these labels right so if I know that be
has to be constructed with CJ then I say
B is labeled with just the constructor
CJ and similarly if I know that it's not
constructed by CJ then I label it with
everything except CJ and this this is
one of the places where if you're doing
multiple types you just you just have to
make sure that you put only the
Constructors of the appropriate sort
they're not all possible constructors
okay so those are all pretty
straightforward
alright so after the little literal
level rules with our same running
example here what's changed well the
only thing that's really changed is that
where v5 ah so this comes back to your
question so now we we do know that v5 is
a cons node not because car was applied
to it but because if you look in the
previous slide we have this is cons
right so the is Kahn's forces it to be a
cons note okay and then the other thing
we did is we oriented these equations
between abstract variables so those are
all oriented now and I think the
ordering is just by number so the lower
number are the smaller ones all right so
nothing to earth shattering yet so the
next thing we have are these so-called
selector rules and the idea here is to
try to make your I guess the intuition
is to try to match the this this graph
structure more in the in the syntax of
the formula so essentially what we're
trying to do is eliminate the selectors
and get everything in terms of the
Constructors so the first rule says that
if you have some selectors applied to
some node you and you know that you is
constructed with only a single
constructor CJ then you can instantiate
you and throw out all the select terms
okay so so this is actually fairly
important so the idea here each of these
selectors we know what it evaluates to
you one through you un and so we get rid
of those selectors and just replace this
term you with a constructor of the you
you eyes okay
so again it's it's it's trying to push
the representation towards a more
constructive representation rather than
a selective representation now people
have done it the other way getting rid
of the constructors and doing everything
in terms of selectors I think that works
too we just chose this way now one one
thing you might ask is what if what if I
have you know car applied to you but I
don't have could or applied then
according to this rule I can't apply it
what we actually do is in the
abstraction rules if any selector is
applied to a node we introduce all of
the selectors and again this is just a
formal mechanism that makes it easy then
then you can apply this rule okay
because we really do want to eliminate
all the selectors at once and we don't
want to worry about whether some are
missing or not so we just in the
formalism we just introduced them all
during an abstraction and get rid of
them all instantiation again in an
actual implementation you wouldn't
necessarily have to do that you could
just keep track of which which terms had
any selector applied and then you could
use this rule there's another rule for
finite constructors that's similar to
this one the difference is but first let
me explain what a finite constructor is
finite constructor is a is a constructor
let's see which only has a finite number
of terms that can be constructed using
that constructor in the underlying model
so a very simple example is the null
constructor there's only one term that
can be constructed with the null
constructor the null term right another
example would be if you had enumeration
of just you know ABCD those are all
different constructors each of those are
finite and it turns out that if a term
if you've reduced a term to the point
where it's labeled by only finite
constructors then you have to
instantiate that even if it's not
selected and the reason this is a
completeness problem where you really
basically we don't know anything better
to do for these terms that could be
constructed with my neck
instructors and to guess which of those
constructors it is and just keep
splitting until we know exactly which
one it is so so the important
distinction here is this instantiate one
rule is a little bit smart because you
only have to instantiate a term if it's
been selected from if the term has not
been selected from we never instantiate
it and in fact we also never have to
commit ourselves to which constructor
was constructed by so that's a savings
but for finite four terms labeled with
my net constructors we don't have that
luxury we have to instantiate all okay
the collapse rules are pretty
straightforward this just says that if I
have a selector applied to a term this
constructor I just get the appropriate a
sub term selected out that's what
collapse one says and collapse to just
is our our special rule if I apply a
selector to the wrong constructor then I
just get this designated term here here
it's called tea whatever I decided to
give my my theory of complete semantics
so for example I might use I might just
always use null there if I do a select
of a constructor a car if I do a sorry a
cutter in the list constructor applied
to know I might define that to be known
for example yeah we're guessing that you
actually remove that selector
like it yes
could be that guitar was used in many
places maybe that'd be more efficient to
keep it around but did you actually get
rid of it right we get rid of it and the
hope the hope is that you well one of
the ideas is to try to define the
designated term in such a way that it
will induce a series of collapses and
and lead very quickly to that case being
ruled out yeah it's good question the
whole point here is rid of all the
selectors and in our completeness proof
you know we actually proved that you
eventually get rid of all the selectors
and then you can build a model out of
the resulting terms
by definition finding constructors were
not having these selectors okay good
question it's actually not quite true
because what you could have is in the
case of mutually recursive types you
could have an enumeration type and then
that type could be the argument to a
constructor in one of your other types
right see it's a little more general you
have to think is it possible to have an
infinite number of of instances of this
particular type to know whether the type
is finite or not it's only if I a number
there so I mean your intuition is
correct but it's al it's a little more
general than that you just have to track
that explicitly ok so let's go back to
where we were so notice we had we had
this w which is labeled by v5 and
selected by car and cooter right so this
is a candidate for our exaggeration rule
and so that's exactly what we do we get
rid of the car and coder and replace it
with cons of v6v seven goes to be five
okay you see it you see that role just
go back there so I have car of b5 is v6
coder of b5 is v7 right that's this
that's right that's this structure here
and now because I have because I know
what b5 was constructed with its a cons
I can actually instantiate that and
capture all the information of that
graph in this one formula it says cons
of b6 b7 is v5 okay so that's an example
of that rule okay now notice
notice what the equivalence classes are
that I have here so that's what this
little diagram is going to do so v6 is
mapped to v 2 v 7 is mapped to v3 right
and v4 is mapped to v1 so so I know that
these are the different terms in the
graph that are supposed to be equal now
it's pretty clear that i have this pair
here where the children are pairwise
equal that i need to do some kind of
congruence closure so we just grab the
some convenient abstract congruence
closure rules you know these are from
from existing work and essentially what
this allows you to do is just whenever
you have you know that two equivalence
classes are equal u and v you can
replace you in you can replace any term
where you appears with the equivalent
term where v appears instead of you
that's basically what all these rules
are doing that there's some the only one
that's not like that is the superpose
rule which says if you have the same
term labeled with two different
equivalence classes merge the
equivalence classes alright so if we do
that we apply this superpose rule and
notice that cons v2 v3 is pointing to
both v1 and b5 so we first merge those
two equivalence classes then after
applying to simplify rule over here we
have v5 not equal to v1 and since we
know that v5 does equal v1 we get this V
1 not equal to v1 and then finally that
drives an inconsistent with our
inconsistency rule so this first example
now we're done and basically for this
example we needed sort of basic rules
abstraction flattening and literal level
rules and then we had to use
a little bit of congruence closure and a
little bit of instantiation and that was
enough for this for this example okay
there are more rules however so we have
to look at another example to see how
those work so here's another example
this one's a little bit more
sophisticated here we have supposed cons
XY equals W quarter of W is equal to
qatar of Y and Y is not null so I think
again it's useful to draw the the term
graph over here so what is it we're
looking at well why appears as a child
of this cons node but it also appears
we're selecting it here but with this
cutter so we have now a two level tree
whereas in the last example we only had
a single level tree and then we also
have null and W and W has been selected
so this is the basic term graph okay and
then after we do abstraction and the
original sort of simple literal rules we
have this structure again the only thing
we know constructed with a cons so far
is v4 because it's a cons node and we've
got nine equivalence classes here so far
all right so what do we do now we can do
some simplifying let's see that's
because we know that B 5 equals B 4 + b
9 equals B seven so we can replace b5
and benign everywhere they appear so
let's do that what can we do now well
notice that we have v4 labeled with two
different sets of labels at this point
so one another set of rules we have is
dealing with these sets of labels and
it's just the obvious thing you want to
always intersect them and if you ever
get an empty an intersection that's an
inconsistency so those are the two
labeling rules we have
ok and then let's see if we go back here
notice we can again do some
instantiation so we have cons v2 v3 or
sorry we have W is before and W is being
selected with car and quitter and also
be three is being selected with car and
critter so we can instantiate both v3
and v4 right which are which is this one
and this one these can both be
instantiated let's see is that right
well we can instantiate v4 because we
know it's a cons node we can't
instantiate b3 yet because we did we
have we don't know what that is right so
we instantiate before okay now what have
we got here it looks like yeah
that's true so we can merge those let's
see if I got that
actually let's see can we do no yeah
that's right that's exactly what this
put the little blue thing show so notice
that Khan's x y and w are known to be
equivalent there and also could er w and
could or why or known to be equivalent
but with the rules i've shown you so far
i don't think there's anything else we
can do at this point so what else do we
need to do well when when i have i
showed you the congruence closure type
role rules which are essentially upwards
closure rules going up the graph and now
we need to do the similar thing going
down the graph so if i know that these
two are equal i know that their children
are also paralyzed equal just basic
unification so the decomposed rule is
the most basic version of that it just
says if I have constructors the same
constructor but with different arguments
and they're known to be equal then I
know the children are equal sort of
trivial case is if I have two constants
that are equal I know that's that's
inconsistent and then finally the cycle
rule tells me that if I can find a cycle
in my graph modulo equivalence classes
that's that's also inconsistent because
my underlying model doesn't have cycles
right does that makes sense
okay this is this is a little bit hard
to parse here this cycle rule but you'll
see example of it is very simple it for
example if I have kharab u equals you
that's the cycle or I guess could review
equals use is a well type cycle where I
know that you has to have the cons type
yeah yeah it's like I said there's
nothing particularly revolutionary in
these rules it's just coming up with
them in a nice way that allows you to
understand them individually okay so
after we do decompose we now know that
the children are pairwise equal here and
we can do a couple more Orient's and
simplifies to get to get things back in
shape so what do we know now well at
this point we have a situation where
we're v3 is being selected from but we
don't know the constructor that was used
to construct v3 right and so in order to
in order to to get to the bottom of
things we have to make a decision about
that constructor and this is where we
finally have to do some splitting so our
split rule looks like this it says if I
have a term that is selected okay so we
don't ever need to split well unless the
constructors are finite we don't ever
need to split on a term that's not
selected but if the term is selected and
it's selected with more than one
constructor including the right
constructor for the selector then we do
the following split we we split on the
case where it's constructed with the
right constructor and the other case is
if it's constructed with anything but
the right constructor now the nice thing
about this is even if you have a large
number of constructors both of the each
of these k splits should you shouldn't
have to do anymore splits on this
because the one on the left you can
immediately instantiate and the one on
the right you can immediately collapse
because now the selector is applied to a
constructor of the wrong tight and just
collapses to whatever the ground term is
so I think this was one of our key
insights is that in the serve naive
approach you do this guess of what are
all the Constructors labeling all the
terms and that's that seems to be pretty
badly exponential but if you look at
this rule you always only have to split
into two cases so that's nice and you
don't even always have to do it you only
have to do it if the term is selected so
I think those were two of our key
insights we got by analyzing this
procedure carefully okay so if we do
that let's take the first case split it
says suppose v3 is a cons node okay so
now we can instantiate and we get this
instantiation for v3 in terms of the
cons of v8 and b3 and then then we
immediately have inconsistency by the
cycle rule because v3 appears on the
left and on the right there okay so that
case doesn't work so we can backtrack
and try the other case which is supposed
v3 is constructed with null now what
happens well we can again instantiate
because we know it's constructed by null
and so we have that null maps to be
three but then we can superpose that and
get v3 maps to be one and get an
inconsistency there okay so that's just
a simple example of showing you how the
case blitz work and in fact now you've
seen all the rules and that's it so so I
think our our contribution here was
really to take something that was some
somewhat well understood this idea of
how you how you reason about algebraic
data types I really decompose it into
simple pieces each of which can be
understood
it stood easily and then we show that
these rules are sound complete and
terminating and in fact the termination
does not depend on the order in which
you apply the rules so now you can think
about strategies like which strategy
would you like to use to apply these
rules and of course a one obvious thing
you might want to do is to delay the
more expensive rules the obvious
expensive rules are the splitting rules
the cycle rule is also a little bit more
expensive than some of the other rules
depending on how big the cycles can get
and that's essentially what we did in
our implementation so so I'm not going
to talk too much about the correctness
proof we had you know we built some
really nasty ordering and showed that it
always decreased on every rule that was
kind of pain but everything else was
pretty easy soundness you just proved
locally for each role and completeness
we were able to show that once you get
rid of all the selectors you essentially
have the makings of a model
the implementation reflect the abstract
ation procedure do you have these
and to a certain extent so it's been
implemented in cbc 3 and so the the way
one of the architecture decisions in the
in the CBC project is we separate the
reasoning rules from the sort of
strategy and this was a decision that we
made a long time ago and it works out
really well here so what we sit what we
have is for many of these rules they
correspond directly to proof rules in
our in our sort of theorem building
section of the code that's trusted and
then the strategy corresponds to when do
you apply those rules so yes we have
specific rules for say cycle or
instantiate and then the the actual core
decision procedure part of the theory is
just figuring out when do I need to
apply these rules and it actually worked
out pretty nicely you in fact it was
kind of fun I could do a sort of a rule
at a time and slowly add functionality
it I did this of course like in a
weekend before paper deadline or
something but you know each hour i had
like another rule working and so that
was kind of fun it really it was really
nice to have that kind of a description
of the algorithm is very easy to go from
that to the implementation
over the lesser we had for all come here
give us this whole series on complete
this
well on well first order the resolution
of a circle
and so if he were here I'm trying to
figure out what he would say this is a
special case of something baby
implementing vampire but i don't i don't
remember enough of what he told this
about so somebody help me here motley
life is some isn't this just some
special case well of what the resolution
based serum well well here's the
difference and i think this is an
important difference to point out
automatic theorem provers like vampire
require if you want to do reasoning
about theories you have to axiom ties
the theory so so sure you can represent
like I've done here you can embed this
in force or logic however the
axiomatization of this theory is
infinite so you can't actually eczema
ties this within an automatic their
improver and the reason for that is that
you have to have an infinite number of
axioms that say essentially the occurs
check yeah curse check axioms there's an
infinite number of dis equality's that
are forced by the underlying model so in
general this is this is I think a key
distinction between smt and ATP is smt
you can reason about theories that may
have infinite x'mas ations as long as
you can find decision procedure ATP you
can't do that on the other hand ATP is
really good with quantifiers and that's
something that we're still working on
religion
that's that termination but what about
necessarily get a decision of the
seizure with vampire yeah that's you you
get a complete my not terminate it with
the formula satisfied now there are
other similarities with with ATP because
we're you know we're dealing with ideas
like unification and they use those
ideas within yeah something we're going
to complete this so there I was like a
huge part of this lecture staff the
right so this builds on all day right oh
I mean I think what it says I think what
I would say is we're using similar meta
Theory where we're talking about
rewriting and termination and orderings
but the actual thing that we're
accomplishing is not something you can
accomplish directly in an autumn it
there that's a good question though in
fact I wish more people had that not
only the answer for the question because
I think this is a common miss
misunderstanding that people think year
ago we wouldn't have even thought gastic
wish but a few years ago I didn't
understand the difference between smt
and ATP but it's it's really clear what
now okay let's just talk a little bit
about strategies um so again yeah just
an implementation question yeah so given
a particular context you need to know
which of the rewrite
aim and so you can actually pretty your
context to that now this is a good
question in fact the way I implemented
it is all of the rules are applied
eagerly accept the splitting rules so as
soon as I get a new a new fact I look I
immediately calculate which rewrite
rules are enabled and I apply them
eagerly and then only when I can't do
anything else that's when I look to see
if the splitting is enabled so so I do
have to do some I do have to be able to
query sort of my term structure to see
if there are splits that need to be done
but I don't need to do it for anything
else because everything else is just
done incrementally on the fly it just
blends strategy yeah that's one strategy
I you know I just sort of made the rough
estimate that is probably a good idea to
be eager about everything but splitting
and it really depends if you're going to
embed this in a big boolean structure
then I think that it usually is always
good to be eager about everything but
splitting but if all you're dealing with
is conjunctions of literals it might be
a different story okay i already
mentioned this that the two
contributions were a stronger side
condition for splitting and the idea
that splitting should be delayed and
this is again a nice thing about the
abstract presentation the splitting rule
is contained in one is all encapsulated
by this one rule so it's easy to delay
it you just don't use that rule your
system do we strategy free right
okay so this was a little thing we did
it I have to admit the same kind of
pointless to me but we got so many
reviewers saying how come you haven't
compared with the published algorithms
and I said well the published algorithms
just say guess and that's obviously more
expensive but ok I'll appease you let's
do it so this is what we did
interestingly it was hard to find any
real benchmark so we ended up just
generating some randomly and what let me
tell you I I think the results are what
you would expect once I interpret it for
you which and the first thing to notice
is that most of the cases are trivial
but of course if you're going to
randomly generate things than most of
the cases will be trivial and so what
you're interested in are what are the
cases where you actually had to do some
work so on the left I've divided the
cases by the worst case number of splits
for the two approaches and of course
most the time the naive strategy in fact
I think in all but three of eight
thousand cases the naive strategy had
more splits and usually significantly
more so once you get out to like over a
hundred splits you'll notice that the
time differential is you know a couple
orders of magnitude between delayed
splitting and the type completion or
guessing approach okay so that seemed
pretty convincing to me and then just to
just to sort of conclude the nice thing
about the abstract presentation it's
easy to prove things about it easy to
try different strategies and it made it
easy to implement as well we achieved
our goals we I think we understood now
what is this theory how do you decide it
how do you implement it and some of the
future work is of course applying the
theory and and looking at maybe richer
data structures now an interesting story
one of the complaints and reviewers of
this paper is how come you don't have
real benchmarks if this theory we're
good for anything you'd have real
benchmarks on the other hand as soon as
I implemented it people started finding
ways to use it and cesare has a has
several nice uses of it in trying to
model type systems and in fact there are
lots of ways that you can imagine using
this theory once you have it in fact I
know you have something similar had
something similar in sound I'm sure
there were lots of lots of uses for that
too so it's just interesting people were
complaining that there are no uses but
as soon as you provide it then there are
lots of uses right so sometimes you have
to work the other way around there's one
other story I should tell here to be
totally honest which is the this is I
think the best sort of i'm very pleased
with this work in terms of deciding the
theory i presented but there's one
little catch which is most the time you
expect formulas to be presented in such
a way that selectors are not applied to
the wrong constructors or if they are
that can't affect the value of your
formula so what we recommend in the
paper and in some of our other work is
using a TCC type of approach where you
build a separate condition that checks
whether your formula could possibly be
affected by these bad applications of
selectors now we didn't yet integrate
this idea into the procedure but I
believe it's the case that if you're
going to go through all that trouble any
way of checking whether a selector can
be applied then when you apply this
decision procedure you may be able to
get away with not splitting at all in
fact I think what you can do is just
assume that the selector is always
applied to the correct constructor we
haven't worked out the details of that
so that's also some future work but but
it looks like that probably it will work
so that's that's sort of for full
disclosure I think if you're going to if
you're going to approach it that way you
may be able to get away with not
splitting it all
that's right finite constructors you
always have this is no way there is no
way out what if you if you have
different such algae rust and a
different sets of constructors
the whole system might have tons of
different constructors does that mean
that you need to keep track of for each
term all of those constructors all be
algebra no you just have to win us
presumably if your formulas well typed
then you just have to look at the
constructors for that type yeah in fact
this was something we didn't know at
first either but once we'd written the
rules and thought about what if you have
multiple types it all works out very
nicely in the paper covered described
site this looks awfully similar to all
the stuff that I've seen it
space typing so trying to put my finger
on what
different so it's in one thing that it
is seems obviously there is a a vehicle
purchases of they never
query in equal so is that the evening
because your sister way you got rid of
selectors that's all stand it never
Texas demands I mean write it in
fretless you don't need
because that's just a packet of sugar in
some sense right so what would is it
that yeah I think really what we've done
is we've taken the familiar ideas types
and we've cast it as a as a first order
theory and so now you want to reason
about it within this setting a verse or
logic and some of the ideas carry right
over and some of them don't exactly and
so it's just it was kind of trying to
figure out if we want to think about it
in this framework what do we need to use
and what do we need to invent and I
think the key ideas were understanding
well first of all understanding this
idea of selectors applying to wrong
terms you have to do something with that
in a first order setting and then that
introduces this question of which
constructor was used and how do you
delay that you will use the musician and
you just as important as you will then
assume that it has to write fun
right so it's not quite as simple in
this first order setting and I mean if
you're given this theory this is how you
decide it if if what you really care
about is whether it's possible for
something to be applied to the wrong
constructor then you have to use this
other well there may be other ways to do
it but the way we do it is we first go
through and sort of annotate the formula
and figure out under what conditions
critics selector be applied to the wrong
constructor because that's exactly what
the hype system stupid is that that's
their whole purpose is determine whether
you ever applied the whole thing right
path and thing and they do that very
efficiently it's all these equalities
that care about you just ooze
unification and there is no splitting of
all ever so that's where
there I don't know
is it all but it used by these
inequalities let's see I I think it's it
could be that things are a little more
decoupled than they are in type systems
because you could have a very large
formula and you could have over here
something about that X is constructed
with null and something over here about
you know a selector applied to X and
there's some non-trivial boolean
structure of your formula that creates a
dependency between those and guarantees
that you're not going to have a badly
type thing so I'm not an expert on type
systems but typically i think you can do
most things with local reasoning and
building constraints and because we're
in arbitrary first order structure we
have arbitrary boolean super structure
and it's just a little bit more
complicated to have those constraints
building everything
so another thing is she said one of the
implications that you have is that
in Coto
I think when you get there actually I
think you're you're bald is not the
right one
you don't have any please ok whereas in
fact if you do represent
these terms of types do definitely one
the second thing because now he's around
them oh why aren't they good enough no
because because the
the terms you're representing in your
model are not the elements of the
types themselves and doesn't
cursive tight yes I mean your list your
list structures like streams or so that
i'm talking about your list structure
here right okay so if you're using in
this case here you're you're modeling
they had the valleys of the lists right
but you can similarly take the terms
that you have and use them from all the
types all selves writings and those need
to be recursive so if you look at type
systems based on set for you for example
they look exactly send citizens that we
call it around you have inequalities
okay and you definitely need the cursive
types there and so evening
and another thing
about application in the time domain is
of course well you want function x all
is totally in
that so have you I mean are you guys are
really thinking of going in that
direction because an icc 10 blocks and
this is really what
types I haven't thought a lot about the
extension to serve higher order stuff
one I think one thing that that I dunno
about that people have used is there you
can encode some higher order stuff by
using the sort of meta applies operator
and I know that like the guys at Intel
have successfully used an approach like
that for using first-order logic to
reason about some high order stuff so
there may be something there and there's
another probe a Christian type of glue
with your type can you come
contravariance
so you don't necessarily get in
you have any thoughts on that Chester
yeah we can talk offline can steal some
of your time
a different question how when you remove
selectors and never likely how does it
interact with with quantifier something
you might not use such as library the
trigger favorite first or your knees
too so that you can do the treatments or
do you just recommend against
using such things of triggers okay this
that's a really good question we aren't
there yet but that's a fair question
because that's exactly what we would do
is we trigger on the selector I think
let me think if if we've solved this
problem already or not I think we may
have because when we remove the selector
we don't actually eliminate it from the
e graph in fact you have to keep it
around because you may backtrack or
something anyway and so I think the idea
is as soon as the selector is introduced
it gets put into our our set of possible
matches for triggers and then if you
actually do trigger and match that
you'll just look up well what is the
current representative for that selector
and so it's in terms of in terms of so
the way in which you actually eliminate
it in the implementation is that it
doesn't exist in the representatives of
any equivalence class but it still does
exist in some sense you know which
equivalence class at sin so so I think
that problem is solved actually good
question
yeah so have you looked at the word fire
McAllister
he's been doing sort of a lot of
think of it as sort of remember that we
ready
or he was using them to express
analysis
it's another firm area worth
looks very similar you
organics for sale
he actually has thought about how you
take this kind of rewrite system that is
very nice as you said profits but it can
automatically take advantage of things
like the union-find algorithm to
implement the Valastro equals class part
of uri right so that might be something
but it sounds a little bit more like
coming the other direction where we're
sort of people already building the
system we've got our efficient data
structures and then we say oh let's see
if we can you know take this thing that
we want to implement and first write it
as a nice rewrite system that sounds
like he's more like saying well let's
take this nice rewrite system and now
let's see how to implement on the
ordinate think he came the same way to
administer really said ah this is great
just an express full or analysis using
mice reading systems and how do we make
efficient yeah of course the more that
can be automated at the better I mean
admittedly once I understood the
calculus it wasn't too hard to implement
but it was that was for me and like I
wrote the system so if someone else
wanted to do it it had been more
challenging so automating that would be
great so do you actually take advantage
of the Union hologram or do you actually
have your rewrite rules
no we we have our own sort of yeah we
have a congruence closure algorithm kind
of built in and we just use that
there is speaking of the delays pretty
did you I mean the screen no comment
backtrack
it was it was just conjunctions of
literals so we were ignoring the boolean
party have look logical backtracking
pepperoni
I think I think that the delayed
splitting would dominate strongly
dominate the lazy splitting because
essentially what we're doing is we're
we're still doing all the splits you
have to do but we're not doing any of
the splits that you don't have to and as
you'll see in Cesare stock he'll talk
about our our our framework for
splitting on demand that's essentially
what we're using here is as soon as you
realize you have to do a split you
figure out what's what to do send it
back to the SAT engine and do the split
does it make a difference move until age
or even speak
you mean if you had a something
dominated by the boolean structure maybe
and it does make a difference that I
show you the experimental results this
was my original question different
berries
yes yes but but it's not there is not
really a matter of the back cracking the
problem is you by doing the splitting
first and maybe maybe I'm not maybe it's
not quite way you're saying the strategy
here was you do all the splits first and
then you then you apply the other rules
and see whether it what happens and
essentially a lot of those splits are
unnecessary there's just big port parts
of the tree you don't need so it's not
really I wouldn't I don't think this the
the the results I gave our that
interesting because I don't think you
would ever implement it that way but
without a nice decomposed set of rules
it's not clear how to know how to
implement it another way so i think the
the inside is by decomposing the rules
it's clear how to separate the splitting
if you just have this black box that
often gives you that doesn't say
anything about constructors it's not
clear how to separate out that black box
from the from the constructor selection
well thanks for much alright thanks